ja was ich glaube ist dass die Schäden
die diese erratische und auch nicht
evidenzfähige Kommunikation des
Gesundheitsministeriums über den
Gesundheitsminister an Schaden
verursacht für die Vorbereitung des
Winters weil erste die Vertrauen der in
die Bevölkerung betrifft dieser Schaden
ist eigentlich nicht der größte der
größere Schaden der durch diese
schlechte Kommunikation
eintreten wird und schon schon sichtbar
ist ist die Diskreditierung der Impfung
und der Impfungen als wichtigstes
medizinisches also ich wichtigste
medizinische Intervention die Impfung
hilft Millionen Kindern und Jugendlichen
schwere Erkrankungen zu verhindern
soziale Schäden zu minimieren die 95%
der Kinder die in die Schule kommen
haben eigentlich die Grundimmunisierung
hinter sich aber bei bestimmten
Erkrankung ist das Vertrauen in
Impfungen zurückgegangen vor einigen
Jahren war gab es noch 1000 1500
Todesfälle durch Masern die unseren
Impfung ist jetzt immer noch 76 Prozent
erst bei Kindern jetzt das Jahrgang 2018
die haben sie diese zweite Impfung
bekommen und dieses schlechte
kommunizieren das Festhalten an falschen
Thesen falsche Informationen
diskreditieren die nicht nur die
corona-impfung an sich oder die
corona-bekämpfungsmaßnahmen jetzt für
den Herbst man muss ja auch wieder was
tun es wird sicherlich noch eine heftige
winterwelle geben und man muss hier
dezidiert und kalibrieren
also die Pandemie gibt es noch in
anderen Ländern wenn ich nach Amerika
Blicke oder nach England bringe Schweden
muss man jetzt ganz aufhören Frankreich
da ist es ja verwendet erklärt warum
müssen wir denn noch was tun wir reden
über jetzt gegenwärtig sich auch keinen
Grund aber im Winter kann es gut sein
und das wird so passieren das ist also
unheimlich viel Krankschreibung geben
wird und für eine Zunahme der Belegung
in den Krankenhäusern geben auf der
Intensivstation und jetzt geht es darum
dass politisch so zu interpretieren und
die Frage zu stellen ist Allgemeinwohl
betroffen über das Maß hinaus wie wir
das bei anderen Atemwegserkrankungen
sehen wenn das der Fall wäre dann müsste
vielleicht wieder eine staatliche
Intervention erfolgen ich bezweifle dass
das notwendig ist oder muss man
verhältnismäßig reagieren du wirst bei
anderen Atemwegserkrankungen es reicht
jetzt genau das meine ich ja staatlicher
Seite übergibt man dann die
Verantwortung wieder zurück oder lässt
man den wieder den die
Eigenverantwortung zum zugekommen und
dann kann sich jeder entscheiden ob er
eine dieser drei Methoden die es gibt um
Erkrankungen und Todesfälle zu
verhindern annimmt die Impfung
Medikamente oder das gesundheitswild Pro
Wagenknecht spricht für sie denn
irgendetwas noch dafür dass wir
Maßnahmen machen und ergreifen also ich
denke mal freiwillig wer eine Maske
tragen will um sich zu schützen sollte
das tun also ich gerade ältere Menschen
die vielleicht Vorerkrankungen haben da
kann das durchaus sinnvoll sein aber ich
finde es wirklich absurd dass sowas noch
vorgeschrieben wird und vor allem da bei
Kindern wo nun wirklich das Risiko also
überschaubar ist übertrieben sie haben
eigentlich keins also Grippe ist für
Kinder also ich bin ein Laie aber nach
allem was ich gelesen habe ist eine
Grippe für Kinder gefährlicher deutlich
gefährlicher als Corona und insoweit
finde ich das alles
wirklich im Bett liegen
ich meine ich finde das auch nicht schön
dass du blöde Viren immer kursieren also
ich ich hatte meine ganz schlimme Grippe
da habe ich drei Monate an den
Folgewirkungen wirklich gelitten und
Corona habe ich jetzt zweimal gehabt
beim zweiten Mal war es auch nicht schön
beim ersten habe ich nichts gemerkt habe
ich nur einen Test gehabt aber ich meine
dass das gehört irgendwie zum Leben und
ich finde es zum Beispiel wirklich
unerträglich es gibt immer noch die
einrichtungsbezogene eben Pflicht also
es gibt ja immer noch für Menschen die
in Pflegeeinrichtungen Arbeiten den
Druck das wird zwar teilweise nicht
umgesetzt weil wir pflegemangel haben
von Menschen wo es umgesetzt wird es
gibt immer noch Menschen die verlieren
ihren Arbeitsplatz also ihre Existenz
weil sie sich
gefunden die ich nachvollziehen kann das
sind ja oft junge Leute die meistens das
auch dann schon sich mal hinter sich
haben weil sie sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen und ich finde das ein Skandal das
so ein Gesetz also dass das auch nicht
vom Verfassungsgericht gekippt wird das
zeigt schon dass da etwas in der
verfassungsmäßigen Ordnung durcheinander
geraten ist und ein Punkt möchte ich
auch Herrn sehr zustimmen also als Laie
als nicht Mediziner ich hatte früher
viel mehr Vertrauen darin was mir gesagt
wurde also ich habe bin auch natürlich
durchgeimpft also bin ja in den DDR
geboren da war das sowieso aber ich bin
auch an sich ich bin wirklich froh dass
es Impfung gibt dass wir viele
Krankheiten dadurch beseitigt haben aber
zunehmend fragt man sich bei den
offiziellen Ratschlägen waren da jetzt
Lobbyisten am Werk oder sind das seriöse
Wissenschaftler und das schafft ein
Misstrauen das richtig gefährlich ist
und es sind ja leider zum Beispiel in
der EMA sitzen Pharma-Lobbyisten und
auch in anderen Bereichen gibt es eben
leider Wissenschaftler wo die
Verflechtungen sehr eng sind aber ist
nicht in jedem Bereich so naja also es
gibt natürlich nach wie vor auch seriöse
Wissenschaftler und
Ärzte Medizin gefährliches Geschäft also
selbstständig und eigenständig auch ein
moralischen Kompass haben
aber es gibt eben leider immer wer das
andere oder auch durch dritten Mittel
durch studienfinanzierungen wird das ja
auch immer stärker und ich finde da da
muss man regulieren also das muss ich
verändern weil wir sonst irgendwann eine
gekaufte Wissenschaft bekommen wo also
große Pharmakonzerne mit Studien
manipulierten Studien ihre perfekte
kaufte Wissenschaft würden sie damit
gehen ja ich schreibe jetzt seit 20
Jahren Bücher drüber das ist ein riesen
Problem ich meine wenn Sie einen eine
pharma-studie zur Zulassung betrachten
dann ist das so als würden sie an der
Schulklasse sagen ich als Lehrer also
ihr denkt durch die Fragen aus der
Prüfung ihr macht die Prüfung selber
gibt euch selber die Noten und ich prüfe
das nicht nach so läuft das gerade also
das könnte man alles ändern aber das ist
eine ganz dickes Brett zu bauen aber es
wäre möglich aber ich glaube dass das im
Corona nicht das Problem ist sondern
eigentlich ein Symptom eine Gesellschaft
die verlernt hat national mit Problemen
umzugehen wenn wir rational mit Corona
umgegangen werden hätten wir gesehen das
sterbegeschehen dass wir hatten ist ganz
normal es war nicht außergewöhnlich
gewesen dann hat dann hätten wir würden
wir auch uns ja es bewusst bewusst
machen dass die Krankenhäuser die
gesamte coronazeit unterbelegt waren die
intensivabteilungen waren unterbelebt
die Probleme die wir dort haben sind
hausgemacht es ist Personal gehen sie
damit dass die unterbelegt waren also
wenn man sich mal die Gewinne anschaut
die waren überhaupt proportional und die
Belegung war darunter weil man natürlich
dieses die Betten freigehalten hat das
ist der Grund Wahnsinn eigentlich was
den Bürgern vorgegaukelt werden es ist
natürlich nicht alles so schwarz-weiß
und ich kann auch nicht bei einem
zustimmen was ich sagen muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen aber dann sind wir noch im
Anhang da eins sagen was Frau
Wagenknecht gesagt hat dieses Vertrauen
das verloren geht wenn man einmal eine
bestimmte Sache nicht auf die Reihe
bekommen hat wenn man also jetzt das
Vertrauen in die corona-impfung
untergräbt unser gräbt man gleichzeitig
nicht nur das Vertrauen in die Impfungen
an sich sondern auch das Vertrauen in
die Gesundheitspolitik der Regierung
also reden die durch die schlechte
Kommunikation durch die erratischen
Auslassungen des Gesundheitsminister und
anderen gesetzt werden gehen viel weiter
als dass man jetzt die Corona Situation
jetzt nicht im Griff hat sondern man
verprellt die Menschen man nimmt sie
nicht mehr mit und das ist ja so
offensichtlich die Statements die da
gemacht werden die Kinder haben sieben
Prozent der Kinder kriegen longkowitz
die Ansteckung kann mit den Impfstoffen
verhindert werden dass die die Liste ist
ja so lang dass man schon Bücher darüber
schreiben könnte und das ist eigentlich
der eigentliche schlimme Teil der
corona-politik aus meinem Blickwinkel
dass man die Gesundheitspolitik
untergräbern auch wieder die Politik
dann letztendlich sind es ja Politiker
die dort sind und die leben die die
Standards Lauterbach ist ja auch
vielleicht wird ja untersucht nicht in
Quarantäne gegangen da muss man eben
doppelt hingucken wenn man Politik ist
am Schluss der Sendung aber hier will
ich natürlich wissen herr Frank sind Sie
sich jetzt gerade einig bei dem
Statement jetzt von Herr Stöhr das sind
wir uns sehr einig und ich glaube dass
die Medizin ein dramatischen
Vertrauensverlust erleben
und wir müssen jetzt gegensteuern ich
kann alle Kollegen wirklich an alle
Kollegen nur appellieren jetzt die auch
spüren dass da was schief läuft dass das
die Argumente nicht stimmen jetzt sich
zu getrauen weil die haben Angst genau
die haben Angst da haben Leute wirklich
echte
Kontraindikationen bezüglich der Impfung
echte Kontraktion getrauen sie nicht
ihren Patienten eine impfunfähigkeit
auszusehen und schicken sie zu mir ja es
ist also unfassbar also
27 Millionen Euro hat die jüngste
Anzeigenkampagne gekostet von Karl
Lauterbach als Werbung für die vierte
Auffrischungsimpfung trotzdem sind die
so viele Fragen offen dass man sagen
kann dies Geld ist einfach verraucht und
hat
nirgends
hinter der Bundesregierung er hat die
Unwahrheit in diesen Kampagne behauptet
das ist also ganz 10% hat er gesagt wir
sein in die Klinik wir müssen wirklich
und wissen Sie was mich wirklich wundert
ist diese Angst die auch die Kollegen
haben sich offen zu sagen wir müssen
diskutieren ist das wirklich so gut die
trauen sich nicht was die Impfung zu
kritisieren zum Beispiel oder die
corona-politik wir müssen diese Angst
überwinden ich meine unsere Großeltern
ja da gab es Gestapo voll der Keller die
hatten Angst
das meine ich doch man kann es nicht
vergleichen wovor haben wir denn Angst
gehen wir doch raus sagen wir unsere
Meinung sachlich aber fundiert und dann
kriegen wir diese Diskussion Entchen
Gang weil wir werden in der Medizin ein
dramatischen Vertrauensverlust und sein
ähnliches
Problem der Ärzte
Immunologen Virologen Präsidenten dieser
Gesellschaften die sich zum Teil nicht
aus der Deckung getroffen ist die
gesamte Pandemie
sie haben doch auch immer Ihre Meinung
gesagt zeitweise waren sie Deutschlands
bekannteste ungeimpft und haben es
trotzdem weiter durchgehalten und ich
sag mal ich sitze im Bundestag mich kann
keiner rausschmeißen ich habe keine
Angst also ich meine vier Jahren okay
ich bin ungefährdet aber ich habe erlebt
als ich damals in einer es war eine
große Talkshow Anne Will da war ich mit
Herr Lauterbach und ich habe ja gar
nicht gegen die Impfung geworben also
das kommt mir auch nicht zu als Laien
sondern ich habe einfach gesagt ich
selber sogar hier zum Beispiel bei der
gesagt das ältere Menschen also sagen zu
können ja an Daten hatte war so also
mein Mann hat sich auch impfen lassen
dass ich dachte für ältere ist das
sinnvoll damals als vor allem noch die
Delta Variante die war ja schon Türkisch
und ich kenne auch persönlich zwei
Menschen die da mit dem Koma lagen also
da habe ich mir gesagt gut für ältere
ist das wahrscheinlich sinnvoll aber ich
hatte eben dort ich lasse mich nicht
impfen weil ich bin skeptisch das ist
ein völlig neuartiger Impfstoff und
deswegen möchte ich das für mich nicht
und ich habe dafür plädiert dass jeder
es selbst entscheiden kann und kein
Druck gemacht wird das war eigentlich
nur mein Plädoyer ich wurde ja
geschlachtet als
wissenschaftsfeinden als impfgegnerin
ich bekam also die schlimmsten Mails von
Leuten die mir dann geschrieben haben
auch bis dahin also eine Mutter ist
gestorben ich hätte sozusagen die
Verantwortung dafür weil die Mutter sich
nicht halt impfen lassen es war ganz
schlimm es war wirklich ein
Meinungsklima wo man seinen seine
Meinung nicht mehr sagen konnte und auch
Menschen die nicht geimpft waren ich
kenne ja Leute die dann in der auf der
Arbeit zum Beispiel richtig gemobbt
wurden also es war wirklich eine ganz
unschöne Stimmung die auch medial
geschürt wurde und wenn man so
diskutiert dann kommt man natürlich
nicht zu einer freien Meinungsbildung
also wie gesagt ich will ja gar nichts
sagen ob das jetzt für ältere das müssen
Ärzte entscheiden und vor allem muss man
wirklich das finde ich dringend Daten
auswerten und das hat mich die ganze
Zeit gestört dass sie nicht erhoben
werden das macht mich auch skeptisch
wenn wenn sie nicht erhoben werden weil
wenn die Daten so gut sind kann man sie
auch erheben aber wenn wir so immer mehr
solche Diskussionen haben in Deutschland
die völlig irrational laufen dann ist es
natürlich so dass ich viele nicht mehr
trauen und auch also wir haben Ärzte
gesagt sie haben Angst um ihre
Approbationen wenn sie Menschen eben z.B
einig und damit sind wir am Ende der
send